haywood heißt yesterday we are taking
chances halloween cache das ist nur ein
bisschen kitschig
hallo leute ich wieder einmal warum
bekommt seine dann frage ich hätte shane
dawson halloween kuchen kirstein
zuschauer hat mir die kommentare
geschrieben ob ich nicht mal scheiden
dorstens halloween tod retten kann
und da kam ich mir das video nochmal
angeschaut und mir ist aufgefallen dass
ich das schon gesehen hatte shane dawson
hatte damals nämlich also vor zwei
jahren ungefähr jeden tag ein food video
hochgeladen und ich habe mir auch jeden
tag ein food video von shane dawson
angeschaut mittlerweile kennen ihn auch
jeder auf youtube alleine durch dj paul
drucken oder mit jeffrey star oder great
white girl chancenreichste gerade
richtig ab und er hat zwar jeden tag ein
food video hochgeladen aber ich würde
jetzt nicht behaupten dass er gut kochen
kann anders als das tor
das problem ist aber er benutzt hat nur
amerikanische zutaten süßigkeiten aus
den usa
kuchen krems alles was wir hier in
deutschland nicht haben und dann begann
die reise für vanessa durchs world wide
web um amerikanische zu süßigkeiten zu
finden
ich erzähle euch jetzt ungefähr was ich
getan habe ich habe einfach alles
gekauft was er in diesem video genutzt
hat was ich online finden konnte ich
habe natürlich nicht alles gefunden und
habe einfach alles gekauft was sehr
amerikanisch auch sahins supermärkten
da war ich richtig froh denn die hat er
auch wirklich im video benutzt sr mit
namen kenne kein angebot vor
über werden jedermann lärms mit kenny
cornflakes forsting bzw eissing habe ich
fertige packung gefunden
denn shane been dass auch fertige
packung ich habe noch nie so etwas
gesehen oder probiert ich weiß nicht was
jeffrey star auch in dieser sheikh halt
immer wieder in seinem topf eingegriffen
hat und eis gegessen hat also ich glaube
es muss zu ehren eckert sein sowas ist
noch immer möglich gekürzt - rainer
riess pieces laut peter kalafut peter
pikl leisteten das ist ganz klebriges
gummi toll wenn wir einen halloween
kuchen machen dann darf natürlich
pumpkin aus der dose nicht fehlen ganz
typischer märkten dann kein amerikaner
macht selbst kürbispüree sie kommen es
immer nur aus der bus soll dann gibt's
noch ein paar braune live spaces grünes
eis oma und da konnte ich auch nicht
nein sagen das sind einfach die form mit
oreo teil
hier habe ich noch eine form mit
normalen teil und lustigerweise habe ich
wirklich alles einfach random in den
einkaufswagen gepackt weil ich dachte ja
okay ich brauche halt amerikanischen
waffen keine ahnung was machen werde und
jetzt wo ich die drei zu hause hatte ich
hab die beste idee um diesen studenten
leute ihr werdet ausfiel eine sache
macht mich sehr traurig und da kann ich
mich gleich beschweren bei dem shop
hallo hier ist vanessa ich beschwere
mich das sind piepst die kennt man
eigentlich als kleine küken in so geld
und das ist eine special halloween form
und ich hatte sie in geister bestellt
nicht ab frank stein bekommen weil am
ende praktisch ein auf seinen kuchen
halt diese pieps raum geister form und
ich hab sie mental an gefunden habe mir
ein zweites loch in asch gefreut aber
unter und das
ist alles zwar schon ziffer amerikanisch
aber jetzt fehlt das allerbeste was ich
bekommen habe war ich so früh original
candy korn
dazu gibt es eine story candy korn habe
ich das erste mal als kind gesehen im
internet und habe es ganz lange als mein
computer hintergrund gemacht das war so
ein bild mit ganz viel kenny konz und
ich wollte immer wissen wie das schmeckt
und damals war ich acht jahre alt oder
neu als ich gesehen habe dass ist
scheint für seine halloween torte
benutzt muss ich das unbedingt kaufen
und wir werden es auch jetzt sofort
probieren
ich muss wissen wie es schmeckt 29
jährige ich hatte ok wahrscheinlich
pures gift und gegen genmanipulierte
stoffe und drinks aber es ist egal ob
man nicht beschimpfen enttäuscht zu sein
[Musik]
erinnert ich versuche euch den geschmack
zu erklären wir haben so ein ähnliches
produkt in deutschland aber auf jeden
fall sehr einzigartig also mein plan ist
es eigentlich drei banken teils zu
machen und sie übereinander zu stapeln
und einfach mit frosting geiler deko
aufzufinden nur drei pumpkins ziemlich
aber ein bisschen langweilig und er
benutzt ja ganzen törtchen und küchlein
und so das sollte mir natürlich auch
deshalb gibt es einen drei schichten bei
gruppen mit füllung von der plan ist es
dann dunkel hell dunkel übereinander zu
stapeln und dann gehts müssen sie aber
natürlich und jetzt gibt's gleich und
wie schmeckt in dem ich rette video wie
schmecken die tricks aus zombieland so
sein so süß ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass man wirklich im laden
schön sagt jetzt ein twingo so wir
machen es auch negativ erst
das ist ja da sind wir mal ehrlich ich
irgendwann mal gemacht hat nicht zu viel
geworden
oh man das clever sohn entscheiden weil
dann guckt das worüber wir brauchen eine
klare geschichte muss ich dir vielleicht
zu schneiden ja ihr braucht jetzt einen
sauberen sport wenn sie
wir schneiden trinkt mit tausenden
heißen messer ist ein richtiger
lightweight guck mal poppig mathematisch
es ausgerechnet hätte shane dawson bitte
sie das video gucken sich aus drei mach
es bitte schön grün im sie die
perversion sollte aber jetzt noch nicht
aufhören was brauchen wir noch um es
richtig auch wenn das haupt zimmer
damit kann man nichts falsch machen das
innenleben ist jetzt fertig und
natürlich brauchen wir noch die
panikkäufe look und die geht so man
öffnet eine dose und wer das bessere
team gesehen hat weiß dass ich richtig
gut ich hatte letztens einmal geschafft
ich kann keinen dosenöffner ich weiß
nicht warum mein gehirn funktioniert
nicht gleichzeitig auch immer den
deutschen dosenöffner
aber heute ist der tag an dem ich
einfach eine dose öffnen
okay das ist noch nicht passiert
die tomatensuppe zu unserem pürierten
banken kommt jetzt noch freier weil ich
mich an einem amerikanischen rezept
gehalten habe kommt es ein cup zucker
und diese mission wir in einer anderen
schlüssel machen wir jetzt unsere gewürz
beziehungsweise mailen wir schon ein
teelöffel zimt besteht ein achtel
titelte ein halber teelöffel muskatnuss
ganz vorsichtig sein mit muskatnuss kann
nämlich heime oder töten
wow das ist gemahlene in bar und er sagt
auch mit rein sicht nicht wie frischer
ingwer
dies kann noch eingefallen dass danach
kommt dann ziemlich alles wir brauchen
einen ein viertel kondensmilch ein
bisschen salz das ist ungefähr sondern
unser gewürz müssen kommt jetzt noch ein
esslöffel mehl verstehen nicht warum
entsetzen herrschen kugeln doch diesmal
mir ein wenn es heißt war das so gemacht
heute ich werde das jetzt mal auf 140
grad backen und wir sehen uns dann
gleich wieder
[Musik]
willkommen einen tag später um einen tag
später die kugeln mussten fast eine
stunde backofen sein und dann noch drei
stunden abkühlen und dann darf nicht
kommen nächsten tag dafür kommen jetzt
aber der allerbeste schritt es geht ans
dekorieren wir nehmen uns jetzt erstmal
einen dunklen boden
raquel diese kruste lied musik und jetzt
warum wir die hier chain hatte er seine
halloween version davon allerdings war
es die gleiche geschmacksrichtungen
deswegen müssten jetzt rechnung bisschen
einfärben und auf jeden fall probieren
oh mein gott es ist zucker und fett und
ganz viele ist
wir machen jetzt für die internet
schützen noch eine helle creme und für
außen rum haben wir sie dann abschneidet
das ist gut weil es recht auch diese
unebenheiten ausgleicht unebenheiten
unebenheiten ich muss ja sagen bei
shannon sieht das ja also der klatscht
ossian oder drauf und die kriegen ist
einfach pure sünde weil er ja auch schon
kennen die mountain machen müssen wir
auf jeden fall noch mehr süßigkeiten
reinbringen und deswegen den wertvollen
die helfen auch gleich bei der
stabilität das ist alles gut durchdacht
ist
wenn ich mal kinder haben ich werde die
beste aller zeiten weil ich den immer
nur so ne scheiße machen werde
creme sein auf diesen machen keine ohr
ist diese schicht machen wir ein paar
von denen hier
er hat sie ja auch rein in den kurven
gemacht egal ob süß weil es heißt kenny
kommen da oben sieht es wirklich aus wie
ein kleines meist könig ins tal die
vermutung des tages ich denke candy cane
heißt andy korn weil es auch aussieht
wie colin was ist eure vermutung des
tages schreibt sie in die kommentare
weißt du gar nicht effizient er auf
twitter oder so dann könnte ich schon
schreiben und sagen guck mal ich habe da
einen kuchen
aber bei mir keine plattform der
verifizierung wird weil ich zu unrecht
ich bin fast 1000 kühe bis zum ja es
gehört ist gehört neuer top 10
jetzt haben wir ein bisschen gehen ja
das ist die farbe geschehen hatte
und so macht ihr eigenes halloween
frostig es schmeckt auch nach halloween
abo sie würde natürlich noch eine garage
auf machen aber wir müssen einfach
erhalten möchte sparen wir uns diesen
sehr anstrengenden schritt am ende raus
vision kit kat betriebliche das ist der
sinn von jay kay ich sag mal so das
erste platz eins bei den bug leuten hier
auf youtube
ich hab mir noch die never ending story
hier ich meine guck mal dieser rand hier
mit dem rand da drüber ich lasse es
genauso und versuche jetzt so die deckel
drauf zu machen weiter geht's mit
unserem decke rating aussehen gerade mal
wie die farbe heißt kelly green ich will
so einem flachen aufsatz draufgelegt
muss man festhalten dass nicht abrutscht
irgendwie komplett fertig nun gut ich
habe ein kreuz gemacht das war nicht mit
80 und schon sind kleine blätter nicht
ich herzlicher kuchen jetzt so alle
compliance herr damit ist jetzt auch ein
richtiger candy kate wird brauchen wir
auf jeden fall noch mehr deckung der
halloween
ich bin immer noch so sauer dass sie
nicht die geister pieps gesendet haben
ich bin überfordert leute wir haben hier
noch mein chains motto ist einfach alles
braucht da noch improvisiert
vielleicht sollten uns auch einfach
daran halten prix hatte auch benutzt
habt ihr bild
und da ich ja keine geister habe machen
wir einfach unsere eigenen geist ich
habe hier vor die live hacks raus dann
macht man nämlich einfach oder eine
bessere idee wirklich du musst jetzt
ehrlich sagen nichts mehr gehört zu den
top picks der tanz dass ich endlich
herausgefunden hat ist dieses wissen wir
nehmen zuerst einen gips und klatschen
ihn einfach hier sogar jetzt kommt eine
brezel die brezel ist nämlich der zaun
und frankenstein ist liebe skelett so am
zaun auf dem friedhof so und in dieser
reihenfolge werden wir das jetzt weiter
dekorieren und dann geht es gleich
weiter
frankensteins monster und skelette sind
auf der party von oben so wechselvoll
hübsch und forderten so kuschelig und da
ist ja schon dorstens torte ist und ich
sie quasi nur hätte wollte ich jetzt
hier nach oben
seinen namen schreiben also falls ihr
das aussieht das geht aus diesem titel
schall geburtstagskuchen dem man beim
bäcker ab wo es jetzt kommen noch ein
paar kenny korns ran weil kenny korn ist
für jeden gut ich sags ja immer wieder
aber diese teure schreiben und diabetes
habe ich so lange nicht gepackt so schön
wenn man so ein tolles ergebnis
wir müssen nochmal zu daten drauf
klatschen uns ist es nicht die richtigen
10.000 kuchen
red irgendwie gefühlt noch was sie in
diesem zwischenraum mir ist gerade
aufgefallen dass ich ja noch die lavid
fis habe die jaschin auch drauf gemacht
hat happy feet f xfc und wir sind gar
nicht so klebrig wie ich sie mir
vorgestellt hab' weil alle sagen immer
die kleben hinsehen aber schlümpfe
kleben viel schlimmer so ich schwöre
dass ich alles unabhängig einfach
gekauft habe ich habe nichts geplant ich
habe einfach nur dinge in den
einkaufswagen gepackt weil ich dachte
hauptsache in amerika verkehr
[Musik]
heilige mutter gottes hates you tube lkw
habe barry schenken deutsch sprechen
überließ man tut es mir immer so leiht
ihn anzuschneiden aber ich meine dafür
werden sie ihr gemacht
man kann auf jeden fall sagen dass sie
trinkt ist man schnell es wirklich
behalten haben man sieht richtig den
pumpkin pie so dazwischen
es gibt kinder die ohren die machen
probleme da ist auf jeden fall eine
menge los das ist nicht langweilig und
nun stellen sich natürlich wieder der
wichtigsten frage wie schmeckt der
dawson halloween cache das ist ein
triple pumpkin pie ok also ich bin auf
jeden fall nicht der größte trinken
merke ich der pampa schmeckt super und
die trinker zwischen dass musik konnte
also falls ihr den shake dorfen
halloween tag nach machen wollt deko
tipptopp flächen biscuit boden rein dann
schmeckt auch nicht so nach eine million
geschmacksrichtungen
wenn ihr keine drinks mixt dann macht
doch keinen fall trinkt israel und
ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch eine
schöne halloween und bis bald kippen
like fahrzeug das video gefallen hat und
abonniert den kanal und nichts mehr zu
verpassen
und ich nehme den ruin party erwarten
gruseliger geschmack